-Our first guest tonight
is a six-time
Academy Award-nominated actress
and three-time
Tony and Emmy winner
you know from such films
as "Fatal Attraction"
and "101 Dalmatians."
She stars in "The Wife,"
which opens in New York and L.A.
on Friday.
Let's take a look.
-May I also say, congratulations
to you, as well, Joan?
I don't think people give
the spouse enough credit.
-I give my...wife credit.
I...give her plenty of credit.
-Oh, that's not what I meant.
I meant, you know,
the rest of the world --
the -- the critics, the readers,
and most of all --
-Yes, I know -- I know I'm
supposed to be impressed that,
somehow, you've wheedled
your way onto this flight,
but I'm telling you --
I am not giving you permission
to write my biography.
Now, would you please...
-Absolutely.
-...leave us alone?
-You made that abundantly clear.
-Fine. Good.
-I'm so sorry.
I just wanted to say
congratulations.
-Okay.
-Thank you for coming by
and saying hello today.
-I mean it sincerely.
Thank you.
-Please welcome back
to the show
our friend Glenn Close,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Hello.
-I'm so happy to see you.
-And good to see you.
-We -- This is, I feel --
This is very nice for me,
because we used to
see each other a lot more
because we lived
in the same building.
-I know.
And Rasheed says hello.
-Rasheed is the -- a doorman
who is very dear to my heart.
-Yes.
-And we miss him desperately.
-And his baby was born, I think,
he said like four hours
before or after Ashe.
-Yes. So, we --
we have children that are
very close in the same age.
And I stop by every now
and then to say hi to him,
but he's very upset
if I don't bring my children.
-I'm upset that -- that Ashe
wasn't born in our lobby.
-Oh, Axel was the lobby baby.
-Oh, A-- Oh, Axel.
-Yeah.
-I'm upset that Axel
wasn't born in our lobby.
-Yeah. I know.
A lot of people, you know,
because we lived in that
building for a long time.
-Yes.
-And then my wife had
our baby Axel
in the new building
and you guys missed out.
-We did.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-We really did.
-'Cause there were --
you could see a lot of stuff.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, this is a wonderful film.
-Thank you.
That was a scintillating --
-A scintillating --
-A scintillating,
action-packed clip.
-Well, I mean,
it is a wonderful...
[ Laughter ]
I think that's good.
I'm glad you're letting people
know that, because, very rarely,
as the performer in a film,
do you pick the clip.
You're often finding out
right back there
which clip it was, as well.
-Yeah. Well, if my --
the character that I play
is very internalized.
So, I mean, that's one
of the fascinating things I --
I discovered playing her.
So, I mean, in a way,
that's kind of
indicative of what's --
No, it's not.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a really good movie.
-It is a really good movie.
And it's --
So, Jonathan Pryce, who's
a wonderful actor, as well --
-Yes.
-He plays your husband,
who is winning
a Nobel Prize for Literature,
and it's really
a film that has a --
a great building tension
as to what it's been like
to be the wife
of this famous author...
-Mm-hmm.
-...for, oh, many years.
Did you -- What drew you
to playing this character?
-Eh. Well, in -- in some ways,
first of all,
I'd never played a character
like that before.
I don't like to kind of
go over the same territory...
-Sure.
-...emotionally.
You've -- You know,
you're the same way, right?
-Yeah. That's why I --
every day is so different here.
[ Laughter ]
-So, that was intriguing to me.
I also kind of --
She -- She --
My mom, who I -- we all adored,
at the end of her life said,
"I'm...
I feel like
I've accomplished nothing."
-Oh, wow.
-And I think that was
because she felt unfulfilled
as a person.
I mean, she'd been a --
our mother and a wonderful wife.
And -- And I thought of her as I
was doing this -- this role --
someone who
is in the background,
holding the coat,
helping with the glasses
and the pills until...
it's not good anymore.
-Right.
This film takes place over
a very short period of time.
-Mm-hmm.
-But there is also a flashback
to when this couple first meets,
and you mention your mother,
but your daughter plays
the young version
of the character -- Annie.
-Yeah.
-That must have been exciting.
-It was.
-Yeah.
-I was so proud of her.
She also, you know --
I mean, it's really hard to be
the daughter of a famous person
and wanting to do
the same thing.
And I -- I thought twice about
letting our director know
that she was an actress,
'cause I knew that he was having
a hard time casting.
And I, you know, I kind of said,
"Well, you know, my...
[Whispering]
...my daughter's an actress."
[ Light laughter ]
And -- And that was it.
And then -- And then
she had three screen tests
and a three-hour lunch with him,
and she got the part.
And I was so proud of her.
She's -- She's beautiful.
-She's wonderful in it.
-Yeah.
-She really is.
You have reason to be proud.
Jonathan Pryce plays
your husband, as I mentioned.
And you have never worked
together before, right?
And yet...
-No.
-...been in this business
for a -- a long time.
-Yes.
-Running a parallel career
with him, pretty much.
-Yeah. We --
We've been in the same time.
-And you guys have
a love scene in the film,
and that was
the first thing you shot?
-The first thing we shot.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
What's that like?
-Um...well, it was fun.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Good.
That -- I feel like
that's a very good indicator
of how the rest of the movie --
-Luckily for everyone,
we didn't have to get naked.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, that, would have been --
No, no.
But it -- it -- you know,
I think we both thought,
"Okay. We're pros.
We don't have to get all,
you know,
kind of nervous about it.
And Lord knows
we've done this before,
so let's just do it."
-Oh, well, that's good.
-Yeah.
-That seems to be a good advice
for anyone in a film.
-And we've done this before
in each of our lives.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Your -- Your daughter Annie
also got married.
-She did.
-And I heard you were --
you were reading a book
at the wedding.
And when I first heard
you were reading a book,
I thought, "Oh, you know, Glenn,
you know, there's --"
-It wasn't at the wedding.
-It was the next day.
-It was the next day...
-Okay.
-...around the pool...
-But, still, I thought --
-...with quite a bit of tequila.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
See, no one had told me that.
But I thought,
"Oh, Glenn, you know,
she's such an intellectual."
-Yes.
-"She's probably reading
a book of poems.
There's something that's
going to inspire this couple."
-There's a certain poetry, yeah.
-But we actually --
you brought the book
that you were reading.
Now that I know --
it's a poolside tequila book.
It's Called
"Farts: A Spotter's Guide."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Fred, do you think you could
maybe guess what this is about?
-It seems pretty serious.
-What?
-Very, very serious book.
-So, this is about --
So, you were --
You were just playing this --
Was -- Were people enjoyed to --
by your fart joke.
-It was hilarious.
-Yeah.
-Everyone was laughing a lot.
-Okay, that's good.
[ Light laughter ]
Thank you for sharing
the part of Glenn Close...
-Yeah.
-...that we didn't know
was out there.
-Well, are you going
to do one of them?
-Yeah, I'll do one.
I mean, by the way,
this is not --
-They also have Latin names,
which I think's --
-Okay. So, here is the
"Flight of the Buttock Bees."
This is
analretentivenus producili.
Wait, hold on.
-Do it on the microphone.
-Yeah.
[ Static crackling ]
No.
[ Laughter ]
I think --
Glenn, I think you wore out
the batteries at the wedding.
[ Laughter ]